okay what is a candle flame really made
of I'm at the Palace of discovery in
Paris to do an experiment that
beautifully demonstrates the answers you
conduct oblast russia b- Mo Rocca pursue
phenomena pendulums electric cell uses
Sharjah Bruce
okay so we're turning an electric field
here you can see that the flame is
spreading out kind of low voltage you
see ah do i zap it way than me and I
mean prevent aw no way a few but de anza
pick up where I want papi you wait
that's very cute it's like a butterfly
our la flama sit on plasma sit on a
media total movie on easy and you can
see that the flame has two separate
pieces to it now one is going towards
the negative plate those would be the
positive ions and the negative ions will
be going towards a positively charged
plate so we see the flame kind of
flattening out but if that didn't
convince you that a flame contains ions
then check out part 2 of our experiment
where we compare the conductivity of a
flame to the conductivity of air which
is normally a pretty good insulator it
requires about ten thousand volts to
break down a centimeter of air so right
now this plate is at about 10,000 you
see that the spark is only a little but
if I put it around the flame we'll see
we can get a bigger spark to happen look
at that yeah
because the flame has those ions in it
it means that we can break down a
greater distance of hair there's greater
conductivity that's awesome you love
doing this right yeah a strong enough
electric field can actually extinguish
the flame but watch carefully what
happens when the flame goes out my god
wait wait wait okay yeah if you are the
Daisy owned on the phone read the cafe
just like in the flame the opposite
charges in the smoke are pulled in
opposite directions now while some may
argue that a flame is not truly a plasma
because it's not hot enough and it
doesn't have high enough density of ions
one thing is for sure it does contain
ions which have important electrical
properties which can be demonstrated if
you have a strong enough electric field
there we go oh now the perfect time you
see that it's just that easy maybe we
should have a look at that in slow
motion excite the